[MUSIC PLAYING]
KIAN CAPLAN: I'm Kian Caplan.
As a neuroscientist living
with Tourette's, OCD, and ADHD,
I study what makes
my brain different
from the average person.
Growing up, I struggled
academically and socially.
Paying attention, sitting
still, and waiting my turn
were everyday challenges
in the classroom.
And I was definitely
bullied a lot.
It wasn't until I
was 14 when I watched
a documentary about Tourette's
and realized, holy [BLEEP],,
I have that.
My life changed the moment I
was diagnosed by a neurologist.
The doctors gave me a word
for what I was experiencing,
but they still couldn't
explain why it was happening
or how to make it stop.
Why can't I control the
movements and sounds I make?
Why aren't there better
treatments for people like me?
These are the questions
that inspired me to pursue
a career in neuroscience.
Yes, it's been hard, but nobody
understands the experiences
and challenges of
brain disorders
better than the people
living with them.
We need neurodiverse
people to study the brain
because our perspectives are
critical to scientific progress
both in the lab and society.
[MUSIC PLAYING]